it is vital you know that's something
that Tom considers a sort of existential
threat you know the idea that Cinema as
we know it might sort of vanish it
shouldn't it can't it's important that
it doesn't not just because it's
entertaining or because you know we're
seeing this on a big screen but
this is a moment when when a lot of
people who don't know each other get
together and share something in this day
and age when we're all on our phones the
whole time we're so insular we're so
isolated Cinema is a really really
important social kind of convention you
know it's a tribe and we can't disband
that tribe I'm talking about theater as
well anytime we're all together and we
don't know who's in the audience whose
political views whose kind of thoughts
on anything and yet we all share that
moment you know